your kids you said that you got a a
pretty good relationship with them now
especially your son
too yeah um
did they ever feed back anything to you
like now that they're adults you know
because the whole thing that went down
with you know the family and the breakup
and the untying of the knot like do you
ever hear from him on that like you know
dad you know
well
i mean yeah there's some things been
said i'm not sure i want to repeat it in
in broadcast form yeah i mean like keep
in mind this is a public broadcast yeah
and
to honor my son
um
but
i will say
that
to anybody who's thinking about
you know
ending like what we okay
we had a 20 we had a very special
situation and my
i mean this is really personal [ __ ] i
don't mind telling you this but it's uh
like okay this woman i married
was the sister-in-law
of a guy who was raised
kind of my dad so he was almost like my
brother right he wasn't he he worked for
my dad's company my dad had a very big
company and he had restaurants and this
guy worked in restaurants and he wanted
to be a designer when we were like 15 16
years old
and i always worked my dad that's how i
learned this trade so early and and i
was a tradesman and
and so we by the time we were 19 we were
built our own house together and uh
under my dad's guidance he said oh i got
this extra property you guys could build
this thing and threw one of his
superintendents at us and we we figured
it out
and he was more of a designer guy and
then we did projects all through our 20s
here and there his name is mark and
nice guy
well in college he he knocked up this
girl they end up getting married
cammy
and um so they had their kids and they
were sort of
you know like they were friends
sometimes i babysit their kids and they
were like friends of family
we still did projects together and then
um
one day five years later there was the
big event in oakland
the oakland hills firestorm and it
burned down 3 000 houses in a day 1991
september
1991
and i get a call from marcus hey man
there's this huge disaster happen
there's all these empty lots you should
go check it out and you know buy some of
the stuff which you set a business up
there and i'll do it with you
it's like okay cool so i went up there
and he had his sister-in-law picked me
up from the airport now i knew her
like
a couple times i might have seen her at
a party we never got you know didn't
hang out too much but
then
uh i
that's how i got to know her but so
there was like this big intertwined
family mm-hmm you know families
entertained and that was the one that i
know becoming your wife uh the other one
she became my wife yeah exactly
so
when i look at what people give up
what are they getting
to go through i mean
i guess if you're married for a couple
of years and it's horrible and you don't
really have a lot of legacy and stuff
i don't know maybe it's worth it but
when you're married for a long time like
i am
and you have
families all
who are all
you know intertwined
and
it's like is it really better afterwards
and so
i look at what my exes created
and
sure she got remarried
but
it's uh
it's like okay so she married this guy
whose ex-wife married
my ex-neighbor
my ex-neighbor
had a son who he was like 20 he was kind
of lost and wondering it was this guy
then my neighbor i said hey duane would
you
take my son for the summer and give him
a job and say come see the world you
know kind of man him up and so i've i've
done that process with probably at least
10 guys i mean other parents have asked
me to put their kids to work and sort of
show them what the hell is going on
because they are whatever they're doing
you mean on the boat or when you were
building no no no this is when i was
working this when i was in my 40s you
know
and
because i ran a construction business
and i also um
you know i'm an engineer and i know a
lot about a lot of things and they
trusted me to because their sons were
just lost at some point i think he was
doing drugs and
he was it his dad wouldn't listen to his
dad so anyway i did this so now
his dad his son actually told my son hey
you know what your dad did like one of
the best things ever and he got my [ __ ]
together and he made me see things
differently
now my life's a lot better i was like
cool but the the
the [ __ ] of now which house do you go
for thanksgiving which do you
you know where do you go christmas and
and your alliance's allegiances and and
the complexity that you develop
in breaking apart families and then
remarrying to somebody else is that this
whole structure just gets [ __ ]
complex and [ __ ] up
so
it's i i
i can't
uh say
you know i just know this is what one
thing like my son has to look at and
some of this i'm just injecting like
from what i know he's going to have to
see it's not that something he's saying
but it's got to be hard
you know it's got to be hard all the way
around so before you go and just say
okay i'm going to pull the trigger and
pull the plug
it's it can be very complex that was my
personal case okay not everybody's lives
are so intertwined like that but they
could be and on some level everybody has
a little bit of that
and
what's the uh
i mean you got two daughters and a son
so let me ask you this question so
given the experiences that you've had in
life right now and
like as you would dispense it to your
own kids or any you know like young man
or woman right now watching this like
like what advice would you give a 20 22
year old son versus a 20 22 year old
daughter like is it different is it the
same advice when it comes to life advice
you know what
the most stable women i've seen
love their father
yeah i would agree with that hundred
percent red flag number one is daddy
issues 100
100 percent and
if you get that out of the way i think
almost everything else can be dealt with
uh
unless you're just like a lot you know
unless they're just come on people are
just [ __ ] up but but
um i was listening to jordan peterson
today and he was talking about you know
like this
all the rampant people changing sex and
stuff and how it's just pop culture
and how screwing things up and the
balances of men and women and
i don't i mean those are those are
fringe
i would hope um but
but you know and i feel a little guilty
about that too because my oldest
daughter hates me and so i feel sorry
for her it's like you know and she was
lied to
and that's the other thing it's like
i and i i i know she was and
um so she's got to go through life being
raised for 18 years by this guy she
trusted and then also in this bundle of
lies because my ex needs to look good
so she can go forward in life and and
get herself this house some overlooking
the ocean hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you